come everybody to the afternoon session
our our first speaker is pastor Mario
Bozell from thank you hi everyone good
afternoon so I'll be talking about
designing smoothing for online
optimization for improved competitive
ratio in online optimization and first
of all I have to mention this is joint
work with my former student reso Avadi
was here and he's now a postdoc or a
fellow in this program at Simon's
Institute so definitely if you have
asked if you have questions about this
work go to Reza he knows a lot better
than I do and the topic of this talk is
a little bit perhaps different from some
of the other talks in this workshop and
you will see the approach is a little
bit different but hopefully there will
be a lot of connections that will arise
and if you spot some new connections do
let us know okay so they're going to
look at a problem that comes up in a
very general setting of online resource
allocation so I'll first write down the
problem parse it and then we'll give a
lot of different examples of him in what
cases would such an optimization problem
come up
so first forget about the word online
let's consider this offline optimization
problem I want to maximize a function of
summation of coefficients times my
variables so linear mapping of these
variables XT subject to constraints on
these decision variables X P so
optimization variables are these xes
each of them are n-dimensional the time
horizon or the number of these variables
is M and if these are convex sets we
assume for now at least there may be
expansions possible what we assumed sigh
is a concave function this function here
is concave and in FX here this is a very
compact form for this function to
capture two things revenue and budget
and later when you look at examples we
separate the role of those two sub parts
of this function but there's something
we want to maximize so you can think of
it as it's a revenue plus negative of
violation of budget it's something like
that now there is a
involved in the setting of this problem
s'okay is a proper convex cone and the
role of the cone is that these XTS
actually belong to a cone and these ATS
are such that they are cone preserving
in the sense that the output a txt also
belongs to the cone and basically the
role of the cone here is that it gives
us an ordering on these 88 seas and
you'll find that useful and the typical
cones are going to be the RN frost cone
the possessive or Sint that just orders
vectors entry wise or the positive
semi-definite cone that gives you matrix
ordering so we want to actually keep it
general because we will use both of
those cones in in different settings so
so far this is an offline optimization
problem if I actually have all the
problem data the soy and the A's and the
FS I can just solve it as a convex
optimization problem that is implicit in
fact in the soy soy is actually
connecting all your X T's so that's why
the budget can be I actually some
examples were from a but yeah good
question so what's the online setting
you're interested to solve this problem
in the online setting online setting
means that we are given before the
algorithm starts or before everything
starts we are given the size so
algorithm that wants to solve this
problem in online fashion no sigh but it
does not know 80 or ft until time T so
at time T there is a these new inputs
come to the algorithm and in this talk
we want to look at an adversarial
sequence of incoming ATF T's but there
are different models for that here
adversarial then the algorithm wants to
assign a new variable XT and once its
assigned X T this actually does not
change for the remaining time so you see
X 80 and ft you decide on XT and keep it
fixed by the way this form can be
simplified a little bit by pushing the
80s inside of T's but that makes things
even more compact and connection to
application a little more murky so we'll
keep it like this okay so that's offline
this is the online problem and our goal
will be to talk about algorithms that
are online that whose value of
objectives that they achieve divided by
the value of the offline problem is good
so that's called competitive ratio ok
so what's an example perhaps the bigger
example that made this class of problems
famous is this problem called the
AdWords problem comes up in online
advertising so for example if your
Google who's running a search engine and
you have a bunch of advertisers who have
given you their limited budgets and they
have asked you to show their ads in
response to a query into coming to the
search engine then when a query comes in
you have to decide which ad to show and
suppose for example query one comes in
then three of the advertisers for
example bid on that query and say that
they want their ads shown and they were
paying as much for it the search engine
has to decide suppose it's an integer
case in which it has to pick one of them
so then if you let's say match this one
and so see what's happening relative to
the general problem that we had before
in this problem those eighty matrices
are simply diagonal diagonal entries are
the values of the bits that each
advertiser makes on this query so in
this case there are only three non zeros
in that we have our matrix and XT is
just a zero one vector that shows this
assignment in this example then the next
one comes in
and again three advertisers bid on it
the search engine based on its own
online algorithm will pick one and so on
and this keeps going and at the end you
want to judge how well this algorithm
did so course for queries came in then
everything ended so what's the
optimization problem for this example so
here the sorry will be some function
that looks like this in the simplest
case it's linear and then flat so it's a
piecewise linear function this is the
revenue of the search engine from the
ice advertiser as a function of how much
it advocated or how many times it showed
it the ad of that advertiser
times the bid of the advertiser so so
it's summation is a function of this u
where u is this for the ice advertiser
this is overtime how much you got from
that advertiser and the search engine
wants to maximize the total revenue so
some overall advertisers of those toys
and the constraint here is that the
excise have to be non-negative and they
have to sum up to one and this would be
called fractional assignment if you want
an integer you can ask for integer but
in this story we are not going to ask
for integer its fractional okay so
that's the problem so we want to
maximize function of this shape subject
to a DFT will be given by this guy and
ATS are given by the bids and the soy is
this shape okay so a bit more general
example is an online linear program
technically online packing linear
program which is of this form so this is
our usual linear program here it's a me
write it as a summation of inner product
of vectors and this one also has a
summation of matrices times vectors that
are equal to some fixed budget B and
again some individual XT constraints
piking problem actually enforces that
these coefficients are all non-negative
and these are also non-negative we can
express this problem in the same
canonical form by writing the objective
over all like this basically we didn't
allow for this budget in our constraint
before so how do we handle it we bring
it up here with an indicator function as
a penalty so the overall objective is
summation of the rewards
- indicator function of how much the
budget is violated and this is the
function that's zero when it's not
violated and infinity it goes to
infinity when it's violated so but at
least with this nasty function indicator
we can write this as a case of the
previous form and what applications of
this it's really all over the place it's
actually comes up a lot in online
algorithms in the CS theory but also has
the history in the or literature in
inventory problems and revenue
management revenue maximization and so
one recent paper on the topic that
actually also refers a lot to the
previous literature is by IR Wang Wang
an year in new year's group and and also
this is a these are some papers that
cover this from the CS literature but
there is a lot more so there's
literature that is inside
these papers also to point out AdWords
is a special case of an online in your
book to make the online in your program
a little more concrete this is the
example that motivates the or literature
so you are have a you have an inventory
with a fixed number of items in it so
the vector B here gives you the number
of items that is a fixed budget and
these are each five items that you have
and at time one a demand vector is
presented to the algorithm let's say
demand vector is this V 1 that says
customer wants a bundle of these two
items and it will pay this much for it
so this is the vector that comes in and
the coefficient of it which in this case
is a scalar so this corresponds to
online LP where n is 1 so X these are
scalars the coefficient needs to be
picked by the algorithm some number
between 0 and 1
so whether to fill the order or
partially fill that order and the next
time another demand comes in with
another bid that is offered and again
they invent - owner has to decide so
this is the this is the general setting
of the algorithm and the problem is that
so if you don't know the future of
course you may run out of budget too
early and then some very good offer
comes and you no longer have that item
in your inventory so that's another
example another example so so far these
examples you can always think of them as
vectors in the non negative or sense and
the ordering was just a non negative
ordering but here's an example where we
need to think of matrices and matrix
ordering so here this is from online the
optimal experiment design so up to an
experiment design is a big topic in
statistics which is about choosing a set
of experiments such that when you solve
a least squares problem with those set
of experiments which is kind of vectors
chosen for linear measurements then the
total covariance of the estimator is
small in some sense one of those senses
is the volume of the error covariance
which is captured by log of the depth of
a matrix and in this case we are looking
at the online version of this problem so
you want to basically minimize
estimation
after n time steps subject to the xes
again bounded by some fixed budget and
some being between zero and one so has
everybody seen online or experiment
design in general it's very design
problem instances yeah okay so you're
familiar to the offline no okay so if
you haven't very briefly very briefly so
it's not the focus of the talks I won't
but very briefly basically you there is
a fixed vector that is unknown and then
there are these measurement vectors ATS
and you take the inner product an
experiment it means you take the inner
product for some noise the noise is
often assumed to be zero mean Gaussian
this is the measurement vector after you
accumulates on a number of measurement
vectors you stack them together solve at
least squares problem the error of that
least squares estimate is its covariance
is the inverse of this matrix and the
more you add experiments so you have the
more 80s that you pick you add rank one
matrices here you make the matrix such
that its inverse becoming smaller so now
how do you measure this dog that is one
measure its volume of the error but you
have other measures I can do max of this
covariance matrix and things like that
so this is very I mean there's a lot of
literature on the offline setting but
not really much on the online so they're
interested in the online setting so so
online setting means these ATS are
presented one by one and then you will
decide how much of your budget to
allocate to each one and in the end you
want to perform well so here the key is
that the cone to be considered is the
positive semi-definite cone because
these guys this matrix that you're
building and these elements that you're
picking and adding are all matrices and
they're all positive semi-definite
matrices so they're ordered with respect
to the PSD cone and that ordering again
will be helpful for algorithms to work
what is the XT that's the some decision
variable for example what proportion of
your total budget do you allocate to
that experiment will be its cost money
or could be if it was 0 1 it would be
pick not pick yes it is here so the
covariance matrix is initial uncertainty
plus summation of athe transpose X T so
this scalar XT if it's 0 its you have
not picked that particular 18 and if it
is 1 you have picked it curious that's a
fraction of that well it could be cost
no it could actually be the cost like
you actually pay half of what they
say--it's cause then maybe they get I
don't know yeah
there could be scenarios where this is a
continuous variable I mean actually in
reality in our experiment design if it's
a very very large scale problem you
really run you take this variable to be
a percentage of experiments of a certain
kind that you're running but it really
depends on application some application
you really need it to be integer so
nature one can visit this integer
versions as well but that's an extra
complication so for now we keep the
variables continuous any other questions
yes
so two vectors are ordered with respect
to the non-negative øresund means that
every an element in the vector is bigger
than the every element it's like
element-wise order and in the matrix
case it's the with respect to the
positive semi-definite phone so one
matrix dominates the other if t arjen
values i mean so we are not yet using it
but we are pointing out which cone would
be relevant for which problem the
coordinate is yeah the soy function and
the corn are known the A's and F's are
not known so here we are going to talk
about online primal-dual approaches so
kind of an optimization persons view of
these algorithms basically this is kind
of a intended to be a quick high-level
view of a set of existing algorithms and
the literature put together in a broad
way hopefully it gives you some idea but
for specific algorithms you have to look
at specific problems then we will talk
about the competitive ratio is the bound
on competitive ratio that can be
achieved by these two classes of
algorithms that competitive ratio we can
bound it nicely if we make an assumption
that is a type of s diminishing returns
assumptions we'll see that later and
once we have that bound on competitive
ratio here's the main goal of this talk
we want to design the problem or in a
way design the algorithm to perform this
to optimize the competitive ratio and we
can do it by designing a smooth version
of that original size function so the
main part of the talk will come when we
talk about that how to do that and we
show we can do it by convex optimization
so the first part is going to be a
high-level view of the algorithms again
these are hopefully familiar algorithms
to you but presented from probably maybe
not the way you usually see them but
let's see okay so the original
optimization problem was maximized sigh
of summation of a txt
subject to X 10ft and it's dual so first
thing to do is write down the dual
problem here's the dawn the dual is
minimized over dual variable Y summation
of support functions of a t transpose Y
is minus the conjugate of the SCI
function so let's remind ourselves what
is the conjugate conjugate func function
of a concave function is the smallest
value of the line minus the value of the
function that's the definition of
conjugate it's just that it since
because it's a concave how'd you get
usually we are used to convex and that
one that's the soup support for us so
this Phi Sigma sub T function is the
support function of the set F T which is
nothing but this maximized inner product
of X with a t3 with whatever value
you're evaluating yet over the set so
maximize linear function over yourself
and that's called the support function
and this is the picture that depicts the
conjugate well we all know it so okay so
that's the dual next thing to write is
the optimality condition for this
optimization problem here are the
optimality conditions arranged in a way
that you see the optimal primal variable
optimal dual variable
note that optimality condition is for a
set of X's right all of them are optimal
here and one single dual variable Y x1
through xn Prime on and one dual
variable Y so the XS have to satisfy
they have to maximize these support
functions but with the optimal Y plugged
in and the optimal y is the gradient of
the soy at on the optimal X's so that's
the optimality condition and the reason
we wrote it is that just looking at this
gives an idea of a very simple algorithm
to try to solve these in an online
fashion and here's very simple algorithm
in the online setting when at time T I
get a t + ft I can try to pick the XT
algorithm can try to pick XT so hat
means what our algorithm picks the
sequential approach pick eggs
that maximizes inner product with the
best estimate of the dwell variable so
plug in the best estimate of the dwell
variable you have so far instead of the
true white star which we don't know and
update the y by plugging in all the x's
that your algorithm has decided so far
and then looking at the gradient at that
point by the way if the function is not
differentiable everything goes through
with sub differentials but for
simplicity we assume is differentiable
so this type of algorithm might remind
you for example of ranked fourth type
algorithms or there are many other
algorithms of this kind and this is just
a small side remark that often times if
this set for example is a polytope you
actually get an integer assignment out
of this but we are not going into that
we don't care at the moment we it can be
a continuous service can be a continuous
X okay so this is one type of algorithm
but it's not the only way to approach
the problem actually thus rewrites that
algorithm or that broad algorithm in a
slightly differently why we writing it
will see some nice connections to other
other fields so here's the algorithm
again that was the first step assigned
the X when we said we update the Y we
evaluate the gradient at all the
summation of a s excesses up to time T
so what does this mean we can rewrite
this thing equivalently using the
definition of conjugate as this so it
says that this is the say equal gradient
is unique so y y hat t plus 1 equals the
minimizer of this problem and if you
look carefully at this this looks like a
problem that appears people in machine
learning have seen a lot online learning
problem these are you the usual what
people call LT is the linear calls that
are coming in one by one this is like
your classifier vector that they keep
updating and this is a regular Iser so
we can view the dual update here as
doing what they would call F TRL
algorithm follow the regular is leader
with this particular regularization
that is the conjugate of psy also others
would call it while averaging algorithm
because this this is
averaging of the previous values so this
step of the algorithm is very
reminiscent of those online learning
approaches which kind of also hints that
this particular online resource
allocation problem it store is very
related to online learning problems in
which people study regret so if you were
wondering is regret going to come up in
this talk it's actually coming in the
door not under primer it doesn't make
sense for the primer but for the door
now so this was all about this algorithm
that decided to do the do things
sequentially can we do anything else so
actually if you revisit optimality
conditions again ideally our goal is to
solve for x star and y star together not
update them one by one can we do that so
I want to time T with whatever
information we have yeah we can also
solve a saddle point problem up until
time T and that means minimize over
whine maximize over X this thing and if
we do that this is actually overall the
convex convex the next convex in Y and
concave in X problem so one can solve it
if you solve it then this gives you
another way of updating x and y so this
will give you a better update we will
see in terms of competitive ratio but of
course it's a lot more computation this
one was less computation and this is a
very high-level way of writing it you
have to actually pick a particular way
of solving this subproblem in order to
talk about amount of computation but for
example some known algorithms can be
viewed as instances of this for example
continuous update algorithm that for
instance has been used for online linear
programming and online concave or online
covering problem in bookbinder and
others is actually can be viewed as a
case of this so this continuous varying
variation of the X and the y together
it's trying to basically solve this
saddle point
okay any questions from the very high
level view of algorithms yep should be
easy to state without ishe referring to
the dual variables right first one is
just saying something honey take
whatever choice minimizes the local
linear approximation the second one is
just saying pick which everything
minimizes the function so far is that
right
that's exactly super reasonable
strategies know exactly they're both
very reasonable strategies it's actually
helpful to think in terms of the well
but you don't have to yeah okay so
competitive ratio in order to get a
bound on the comparative ratio we need
an assumption so we're going to first
make this assumption on our site
function we say that soy satisfies
diminishing returns so this is actually
what we call a diminishing return it's
consistent with other definitions of
diminishing return but it hasn't been
exactly written this way okay so if a
vector U is bigger than vector V with
respect to cone K so this was here's
where the ordering comes in if this
vector is bigger than this one with
respect to K then the gradient of soy at
you is this than gradient si at V with
respect to the dual cone so if K is RN
plus this just says if the vector is
entry voice increasing the value of the
gradient entry wise decreases it goes
opposite to the vector or it has its
anti zone so or so the more the more
your value increases the door your so
that's why it's like diminishing return
so what's the result then under this
assumption the simplest form of the
result is for the monotone sorry
function and actually as we saw in the
morning in need stock it's also monotone
non monotony vain' in the stock modular
optimization contexts are very different
from each other
monotone is easier we state this first
form on at home but one can also do
things for non monotone functions so for
a monotone
concave saw that also satisfies
diminishing return assumption
simultaneous update approach achieves
the following competitive ratio the
value of the algorithm divided by the
optimal
objective value is bigger than this
thing one over one minus alpha of soy
this alpha of soy is a quantity related
to the function soy which is defined
like this it's the smallest value of the
ratio of the conjugate of soy evaluated
at the gradient of soy divided by the
function value so conjugate evaluated at
gradient divided by function value and
actually in try to interpret what this
is but before let me say that for the
sequential update algorithm is such a
similar bound as possible but you'll
have another additive term it's a little
more complicated but let's see let's see
what this one means so this quantity
alpha is in a way for those familiar
with submerged varieties to us is a
little bit related to curvature of some
modular functions a little bit in the
sense that is measuring deviation from
linearity so here here it is in a one
dimensional case if soy is one
dimensional at point two zero I draw the
tangent I look at the offset that gives
me this value it's the negative of the
conjugate had at the derivative this
value then divided by the function value
which is this thing so basically we are
looking at the ratio of this thing over
this thing overall the use take the most
negative one and that's the Alpha so for
example alpha is going to be zero if I
have a line going through zero for a
perfectly linear function is zero and
another extreme is for the adwords
function which was nine and then
completely flat for that it's minus one
so these are the extremes of alpha so
you can see it's sort of trying to
measure curvature or deviation from
linear so and only quantity of the site
function that mattered in the
competitive ratio was this thing this
alpha so the proof I won't go through it
it's actually simple and fairly standard
you basically keep track of the primal
value that the algorithm is achieving
and also define some dual related
quantity which is this guy and bound the
gap between the two and show that the
gap between these two sort of a primal
sequence to a sequence is bounded by the
conjugate of soy evaluated at the last
estimate of the dual and
then so we have a bound on this gap then
this does not give us here at a
competitive ratio but bringing in the
diminishing return assumption we can
show that this door like value is bigger
than the true restore so this second
part uses diminishing return I'm putting
them together we get that the
competitive ratio is bigger than 1 over
1 minus alpha and we know for monotone
functions alpha is bigger than minus 1
so this automatically means competive
ratio is bigger than 1/2 that's always
true which is good but of course if you
have specific site function you can
measure its alpha and get a better
competitive ratio and more importantly
for us was that we want to actually
design that alpha we want to modify the
size so I started alpha becomes better
so we get a better competitive ratio
what happens for non monotone functions
is actually much more complicated this
bound still holds however to actually
bound it and get something non-trivial
not get 0 you need to actually make more
assumptions on the problem data you have
to kind of restrict your adversary a
little bit or you how much effort the
adversary's putting in shows up in your
bound this is analogous to the role of
bit to budget ratio for example in
bounding competitive ratio of online
linear fighting problem
okay so this brings us to the part that
we want to focus on which is to design
so what is bad about so how can we
improve this alpha basically for a given
site so when the algorithm starts I'm
going to knows the size function it does
not know the A's and the FS but it knows
the SOI can it do anything to improve
the situation so the problem with for
example this is the SOI of the AdWords
problem the problem with this one is it
is very discontinuous so well it's very
non different so it has this sharp
corner and the problem is if one applied
greedy type algorithm where you applied
the first sequential algorithm to this
function
it's the algorithm does something really
bad and stupid in the sense that it just
takes everything that comes in until it
runs out of budget the reason is it
takes this first value that came in
looks at the slope at that point slope
is 1 so it's encouraged to take the next
one it's taking the next one slope is 1
and then later when it's tries to take
the third one it's out of budget already
so the algorithm was in a way
intuitively too aggressive whereas if
the function looks like this things
would have been better because here it's
as if the algorithm is backing off as
it's getting closer and closer to
running out of budget it's becoming more
and more conservative so this curvature
is plays a big role
but what's curvature is good for each
problem is it's not obvious actually for
AdWords for this problem it can be
worked out but in general how does one
smooth the function side
and what happens if I smooth sigh well I
can take my original problem that was
given to me with a sigh in it I come up
with another function sigh yes i plug in
the situs into my algorithm so I assume
that I'm optimizing with Saez that means
that the two sets of algorithms changed
like this in the sequential algorithm
the only changes you're regularizer in
the in the dual update changes to
something else instead of conjugate of
sigh is conjugate of some smooth
function in the simultaneous approach
it's also shows up here again as some
sort of regularizer
well then the problem means I'm changing
the problem to something else I solved
that something else but I still want to
judge the algorithm with respect to the
original problem
that's what competitive ratio does so to
do that we have to again take the ratio
of what's achieved by the algorithm over
the initial problem and we do that we
can show competitive ratio is bounded by
again 1 over 1 minus a new alpha which
now actually is combining both sigh and
sigh yes so you can maybe think of it as
a curvature of sigh s with respect to
soy which is now defined like this so
it's again conjugate at the gradients
but at the gradient of a new guy minus
the value of the new guy divided by the
value of the function and if so is
equaled so this is just exactly what we
had before so that's good we have this
freedom of modifying the function and
seeing if things can get better this
brings up an a related idea in an
optimization which is called smoothing
via conjugate functions and this is
actually used in convex optimization for
example for non smooth optimization
problems you take a non smooth problem
you come up with a way of smoothing it
and solve the smooth problem for example
using gradient descent and then say
what's the complexity what you know
trade-off how much you smooth with the
benefit in complexity so that's why idea
is actually old it goes back to about
circles for like maybe even order to
Moreau and so on so it's an old idea and
the way to smooth it is in all these
papers is I
a strongly concave function to the
conjugate of the original function so
it's as if you construct the sy sy ID by
figuring out a good fight taking its
conjugate putting it here conjugate
again get Esaias so people in continuous
optimization are probably used to this
maybe others are it but doesn't doesn't
really matter it is a way of coming up
with a smooth function so we can think
of can this approach work for these
problems we just talked about for
AdWords problem in five years
one can it basically redo existing
literature in a way that it's as if they
fixify and plug it in and that's why if
you do that that's why I will be
actually a shifted unscaled entropy
function and when you plug it in the
algorithm it gives you the familiar
multiplicative update algorithm with a
very careful chosen set of parameters
and that leads to the 1 over 1 minus 1
over e optimal a competitive ratio for
the AdWords problem and this is done I
think in several places but one that
analyzes it nicely and also gives the
shows that this is I think this was
shown to be optimal in metal but also in
Devon or engine in 2012 it's done in a
careful way and optimized as well so
that's for just for AdWords for online
LP packing uncovering packing was the
one we discussed covering is kind of
it's due on similar approaches and very
nice algorithms are known due to a
bookbinder nor and authors and other
causes that give the best-known
competitive ratio there is a site in the
end where I kind of this the known
instances of results in the literature
but for us the problem is we don't know
how to pick this best Phi basically you
need a lot of clever ideas to
handcrafted for each problem but if I
have a general problem is there a way to
figure out and also maybe I don't want
to plug in a strongly concave I maybe
this file better not even be concave so
in general how do I pick this smoothing
actually yeah because I mean the the
science needs to be concave but you can
so yes we want to be concave so we want
to actually the optimization problem to
work but but the thing that you added
and then to conjugates it's not so I
mean for example in lesser of this would
be l2 norm squared very simple things or
a1 or something like that but usually l2
norm or weighted l2 norm but we don't
want that maybe you want something more
complicated let's see and actually it
doesn't need to be concave but there
will be an example coming though ok so
how do we design after all so let's just
actually write down the optimization
problem or find me the best site as for
this purpose so for the simple case we
can write down the optimization program
and it's quite practical simplest case
is this when the sigh is separable so
it's a summation of so I of UI which is
the case for example in Adwords these I
indicated the different advertisers and
we want to design the smooth side s to
optimize the competitive ratio bound so
it's essentially one optimize the alpha
as a function of choices of science
however the constraint that sorry s
needs to satisfy for our bounds to be
valid is that it has to satisfy that
diminishing returns so also impose
diminishing returns on your site and we
can do this offline because we only need
to know so so if this design problem is
actually not very efficient or fast
doesn't matter it's an offline problem
once we solve it then we run the
algorithm online with the soy as
Freudian as the data comes so the
optimization problem would look like
this we need to maximize the alpha
that's exactly the alpha in the
competitive ratio over the variables
alpha and the function y so this is now
a continuous infinite dimensional
optimization as it's written Y is a
continuous function on the domain 0 to
infinity and this Y actually is the
derivative of soy it was easier and
we'll see later that this is more
convenient to parameterize in terms of
the
website so we changed variables to Y so
this is basically sy s - I conjugate of
sy Prime oversee the star equal to 1
minus alpha right is exactly that same
equation we had before
now we need to optimize overall voice on
alphas this condition guarantees that
the SOI s that comes out satisfies
diminishing return also in this
one-dimensional case it guarantees that
this is that comes out is concave so
it's infinite dimensional problem so
technically sort to solve board for this
one-dimensional problem we can easily
discretize it simply take discretize the
function y and also the is interval is
infinite so truncate this interval for
specific application problems there is
very reasonable ways of truncating so
for example in Adwords the function of
flattens in the end so you can always
truncate it without losing anything in
other cases you may lose something but
numerically it's not bad so subject to
that those numerical issues we can solve
the problem so here's one example where
we did this AdWords problem was linear
and then completely flat we just took
that and modified it to an objective
function that has two break points so
AdWords with two break points it's
basically this piecewise linear function
and we run the algorithm the design
algorithm that we had on it and we got
this thing this is the smooth toy that
we got the blue curve then we wanted to
see if this corresponds to some Phi if
we had used this nester of style
approach so we took the conjugate of
this blue guy and subtracted it from
conjugate of the original function to
see what's the conjugate of the function
that was added and turns out that what
was added was not a concave function so
in this example it does not correspond
to finding a single fight in the model
of basically the net sort of idea then
we thought of something else because
there was very clever ways of solving
AdWords with a single break point can
one take that clever idea and do it for
two break points if you want to do that
you can think of the following
okay so this
function is a summation of this single
breakpoint function and this single
breakpoint function I can smooth these
individually without the numerical thing
just by using the trick in let's say
Devon or and Jane paper and you come up
with two smooth function then add those
how long would this two so this actually
does fine
but not the best so this is a comparison
of the what function was added if you do
the computation on approach or if you do
this handcrafted approach and the
handcrafted approach suffers in the
competitive ratio a little bit
so one gained something by doing the
design by solving the optimization
problem and let's see okay I have enough
done any questions so far I was also
going to point out there's a the only
place I have seen that this in the CS
literature where something like this was
done was was actually in the Devon or
and Jane 2012 on I on AdWords with
concave return and what they do is that
in in order to tune their algorithm they
actually say they need to solve a
differential equation in fact the
differential equation they solve is this
constraint satisfied with equality so
whenever this decides right with
equality this is equivalent to a
differential equation because we wrote
it has an integral but you can also
there was a prime here the derivative
and in the AdWords case and problems of
that form it's in the adwords itself
it's simple enough to solve it
analytically it's a linear ordinary
differential equation you can solve it
you get exponential as the solution in
the AdWords with concave return is not
analytical but they want to run Jane
suggests that you can you make this of
it and find the right constant
unforgiven forget in the algorithm so we
can think of this optimization problem
as generalizing that that view that
philosophy that you want to optimize and
find what's the best algorithm for this
specific side
so then I wanted to also show in more
recent work we decided to look at that
going back to that optimal experiment
design problem where the variable was a
matrix we wanted to see if we can do
this design thing there and it's
actually trickier but also very
interesting because there you're solving
the problem over matrices so the problem
there can be written as this you want to
maximize some function of in experiment
design these BT's are ranked one
matrices 8080 transpose so 8080
transpose times XD so that was the for
example covariance of the error after
running em experiments or after running
whatever set of experiments plus this
thing can be penalizing your budget
function so I removed the summation of
XT minus B less than zero from
constraint put it here with some penalty
so if this penalty is the indicator
function like that this is exactly
equivalent to the experiment design
problem now for a certain class of
functions H we can write down the same
design problem this class of functions
are called trace functions so there are
spectral functions functions of eigen
values of the underlying matrix but all
the eigen values go through the same
scalar function little H so for example
log of determinant that's one case so
the function would then be log so a lot
deaths of identity plus or Epsilon
identity plus u the little H
corresponding to it is the log of 1 plus
u or another and this as we saw comes up
in the optimal experiment design another
example is trace of epsilon times
identity plus u inverse and this comes
up in a optimal experiment design it's
another criterion in experimental design
and in here it will be the corresponding
little H is 1 over 1 1 minus 1 over 1
plus u something like that
okay so so the question yes so with you
when an indicator of a census part of
your objective and you smooth and do you
lose something in terms of visibility
you might so the certain type of result
can be can be expressed as here's the
ratio of the objectives that you get if
you allow this much violation of
constrain so maximum value of any of the
constraints being violated is blocked
for example or you can enforce
feasibility of the constraint but then
lose and the ratio that you get so if
you really want to speak to satisfy a to
get worse results if you allow some
violation you get better results and
actually I will write down the result
for this that allows for violation and
trades of the two things yeah it's a
very good question yes it does not
you're right if our sorry s satisfies
diminishing return you're okay so
basically we can replace it by an
approximation of it that satisfies and
that's a very good question because yeah
if you look at it if you look at
discrete experimental design then if you
ask the question is this sub modular in
the subset selected the answer is this
one's not so much lower well this one is
so much other and in our language oh
this one does satisfy the Machine claim
this one does not but for us as long as
we can find a good approximation in some
sense this is the smooth version that
satisfies the dimension really what's
that
no not really we saw you get some beard
see actually we saw some numerical
examples later so if there is an
interpretation if there's a way to give
insight to it that we great actually
but so far yeah we don't know so that's
the matrix version of the problem and
uh-huh so now here one can write the
design optimization problem similar to
what we had before so let's try to do
that the only thing is I wrote this
problem a little differently than the
one that had a single sign now I saw has
two pieces HP sign GPS and but it's okay
so it means that I have to find the
smooth version of this and a smooth
version of this so there are two things
to solve over HS and GS smooth version
of each of these for the H part we want
to find a little H s such that it
satisfies diminishing return and for the
g part we want to find the concave
smooth G function our goal is to
maximize the competitive ratio we can
also express it to say and also minimize
budget violation and trade these two
things off so the most general case
would be to pick a trade-off parameter
to capture the trade-off between the
computed ratio and the budget and then
let this gamma vary and actually that's
towards your question we get a different
trade-off between them so again we can
change variables for the H part to its
derivative little Y and here's the
optimization problem now we wrote
something strange-looking here but this
is this is really nice because we needed
to represent functions whose derivatives
are monotone over this over the positive
semi-definite cone functions of matrices
whose derivatives are more monotone and
it's a very cumbersome it's in this case
we cannot discretize in a brute-force
manner that we did for the RM plus case
right so we need a good representation
of functions that satisfy this one
attorney city and it turns out no nerds
theorem provides that so all matrix
monotone functions have a very nice
representation in terms of this for
integral form with respect to a measure
and so here mu is a measure
lando is this the variable inside the
inter
these are a certain type of rational
functions and they're integral gives you
discover the class of all matrix
monotone functions so what I've done by
writing this is that the derivative of
our desired function is now enforced to
be monotone so it satisfies dr so it's
very nice that doehner theorem actually
allows us to represent that set that you
want to optimize over in a nice way
because otherwise if you don't have a
good representation this is it's not
obvious how to do this at all
and then even even if I write the
optimization problem is useless so it
was good to have this and this
constraint is exactly the same as before
and this UMAX is where i truncated the U
I still need to do this truncation and I
may lose something there but again in
practice is not bad so it's just a
variable here that this set of equation
equations have to be satisfied for all
your the may fix you actually let me go
back to the problem we call this whole
matrix u the variable that appears
inside capital u to the lid of U so
capital u is a matrix I H is a function
is obvious I can value so this would be
little use the little user ID like
everybody's sorry about the Congress on
notation but at this point we now have
again a continuous optimization problem
but again infinite dimensionals we have
that we have to discretize and a little
bit worse because then it's that there's
an integral we also need to discretize
as well but as long as we discretize
then finally and finally enough each is
just a one-dimensional integral so we
have to minimize over beta and you and
the measure knew this better subject to
these constraints the gamma was a fixed
constant that we picked that is exactly
the trade off parameter between
competitive ratio and violation of
budget so we can fix
like this forget in here and sort of
with I didn't say what happens to the G
so this this optimization problem finds
the HS the smooth H now what happens to
the G part the G part actually happens
to have an easy solution so you can
write down the condition that or
inequality that G needs to satisfy the
GS the smooth G but that is actually
equivalent to a very simple differential
equation that can be solved in closed
form and this is its solution it's in
fact a convolution of an exponential
with H Prime this is the first order
differential equation with H Prime on
the right-hand side so naturally it
gives this solution and so this is nice
so the G part can be solved and Soglin
and you only have to computationally
solve for H in the end what do we get we
can express the theorems of this kind we
can wait at different ways all of them
are very messy but here's one of them to
say what we get so if the UMAX that you
truncated after is picked large enough
and so from here we see it does not need
to be too large it just needs to be
larger than the maximum eigen value of
all the data that came in if you kind of
know that there is a big number that you
know no matrix bigger than that is going
to come that's good enough for this for
truncation okay if the truncation is
picked well then with HSN GS for GS of
this form whose derivative is this and
HS that's the solution of the
optimization problem on the previous
slide we can show the objective divided
by up so that this site would be
compared the ratio is 1 over gamma over
Y minus 1 plus beta and beta is the
solution of the optimization problem
because so we get a constant bound on
the competitive ratio and aha here's the
budget violation with budget used is
messy number but it's actually related
to this the inverse mapping of the
derivative of GS evaluated at a certain
point the initial slope of H times the
largest trace of the incoming matrices
yeah so so so basically this gives you
we are trying to actually find a good
interpretation and maybe reduce it to
special cases but so far we haven't
gotten ya boys in Jesus but Yama was
actually a fixed number that we picked
to trade off basically budget violation
and uncompetitive yes that's right
that's right it's a little implicit and
strange GS itself depends on you know
but you yeah you still have these
quantities even if you write it actually
yeah yeah because this is exactly the
budget violation so if you say this is
less than something then that something
will show up here but
so one can get a competitive ratio that
trades off with budget violation for
this general class of problems and once
you design it whatever comes out of your
design gives you how to get that
so that better that comes out of the
optimization problem with the HSN GS
give you this whistle oh oh
somehow this fitters aren't showing up
very well but here is an example of GS
and smooth years so GS one one example
would be the negative indicator function
and negative indicator for example at
the budget goes to minus infinity and
after smoothing it could be for example
with different gamma parameters is this
or this so if you're using the screen
one it's really allowing you to violate
the budget if you're using the red ones
only a little bit so there is that that
kind of trade-off but they're all not
satisfying the budget exactly these two
so this is for certain llamo you get
this GS in closed form and then we solve
the optimization problem we get this
blue HS from this original H this
original H itself was even smooth this
is the problem of log u 1 plus u so it's
smooth already but you can still do the
design to get a better curvature and one
thing that is very strange is this is
the underlying measure mu of land or
that you get it can look very strange we
don't really have any insight in some
examples this actually got us in a nice
atomic measure but in some examples it
was not so we don't yet have a good
insight about that but basically this is
smoothing the problem of the optimal
experiment design and we can also do it
for the a optimal experiment design and
here you can see that for example if you
also want to see how budget violation
ratio changes with respect to this
trade-off parameter you can see that
it's going down and this is with the
different values of that P prime found
on V Prime and this is competitive ratio
versus the gamma again gamma is that
trade-off parameter so if you your
company
ratio is better if your llamo is smaller
and again you can trade off
what will compare the ratio is better
you are actually violating budget so
again we can numerically solve for these
and some related this shirt before I
finish I wanted to mention again so in
the in special cases there's a lot of
work done online primal dual algorithms
in there are in many many papers I did
not do a good job at all of reviewing
the literature so sorry about that but
import if not for example Sofia an info
finder have shown this for online linear
program and the one the paper I did
mention was matching with concave return
of Devon or and Jane they have also
basically they're competitive ratio
there is implicit and relates to the
solution of a differential equation
that's the closest to our design idea
and there's an a very nice set of papers
that generalize the online LP work of of
Sofia and others to convex covering and
packing problems and they still get nice
competitive ratios in terms of the
largest problem data and a parameter
that is very much like our alpha shows
up in in their bound as well so it would
be very interesting to explore these
relations more also another interesting
relation is connection of competitive
ratio to regret in this sense of you're
looking at regret when you go to do on
and that has been pointed out in several
papers in particular there's this paper
of Devon Ron Agarwal is actually quite
nicely the paper is about a different
topic and it looks like a stochastic
online setting so it's very different
from ours but it points out that you can
look at regret bounds for online
learning as a black box and on the wall
and then use them to relate it to the
competitive ratio and so summary and our
papers on this if you interested or end
their thanks
so we have time for several questions um
so I don't know too much about that I
didn't really look into the integral of
thing but sequential update algorithm if
for example those sets of T's were
polytopes because you are memorizing a
linear function over a polytope gets to
a corner of the polytope and if those
corners are integer for example if that
was simplex then it automatically gives
you an integer solution and that's why
people often like this kind of
sequential thing versus the versus the
continuous modifying version because it
automatically gives you something
integer but if you decide to use the
continuous modifying one then you have
to round in the end and take it for
specific problems there are some very
nice results what we didn't really work
on that aspect
so sorry so it's a random order model
you might say the couple presents at the
end that your analysis give any insights
into they compare your basis of design
model they haven't yet actually done
that so we don't know the thing that was
nice here is that diminishing return
gives a very nice guarantee and we have
nice ways of imposing dimension return
in the Socastee case that's not really
there so it's a different you know so
actually I that's a good question I
don't know the answer whether design
approach can be helpful for the
stochastic setting or not what do you
mean what does degenerate
for example the sequential
I think it's okay I think if the org max
is a set anything in this set is okay
overall I mean that is the high level of
generality yeah I mean if you want to
pick specific FS and specific size and
analyze them actually what's happening
and what's the rate for that particular
algorithm then one has to make it more
specific I guess this is a bit high
level to really delve into what happens
inside the algorithm like if you're
doing Frank for for example you're doing
this type of thing but then of course
the behavior Frank or V depends on what
sets was there and what's the properties
of those set and the performance is in
terms of properties of the set
thank you very much thank you